hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump sparking a firestorm of
reactions taking to twitter
to ask if the november election should
be delayed
citing coronavirus concerns and
questioning the integrity of mail-in
voting
fox news sunday host chris wallace
shares his thoughts on the motives
behind mr trump's controversial tweet
who presumptive democratic nominee joe
biden may choose as a running mate
and the passing of former gop
presidential candidate
herman cain and with ongoing social
distancing mandates the covid 19 crisis
continues to interfere with many
fundamental aspects of religious life
pastor of first baptist church in dallas
and fox news contributor robert jeffress
joins the rundown along
with rabbi bregman to discuss the
role faith is playing amid the pandemic
and the debate over large services being
held
plus commentary by university of
california at berkeley law professor
john yu the fox news rundown is a daily
news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com i'm
ainsley earhart i'm brett baer
i'm katie pavlich and this is the fox
news rundown
friday july 31st 2020 i'm chris foster
fox news sunday host chris wallace says
about president trump's suggestion we
delay the election
i think the president is just trying to
get people talking about the danger
of or the what he thinks the inaccuracy
the possibilities for fraud
in mail-in voting but having said that
he
is just going to set people's
hair on fire i'm jessica rosenthal
how are you spiritually coping through
this pandemic
many of us have some questions about
this virus that maybe
only god could answer this would be a
prime time to focus on
things that perhaps we should have been
focused on
more all along or to put it more bluntly
this pandemic is a reminder that we need
to be prepared for death
and we need to make sure we're in the
right relationship with god
and i'm john you i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's another week of a lot more
coronavirus deaths layoffs and word that
the american economy shrank more than
ever before due to the pandemic
president trump suggests on twitter if
it's not safe enough to vote in person
maybe we should delay the election
rather than have a lot of what he claims
will be fraudulent mail-in voting
the president saying later at the white
house i don't want to delay
i want to have the election but i also
don't want to have to wait for three
months and then find out that the
ballots are all missing
and the election doesn't mean anything
that's what's going to happen steve
that's common sense
and everyone knows it since 1848 the
presidential election has been held the
first tuesday after november first
and this year ready or not that's
november third as for the idea of
changing it
first of all he couldn't do it uh it's a
one the the election date is set by a
federal law
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday one of the chances nancy pelosi
is gonna delay the election
uh this would be a bill that would have
to get through the house as well as the
senate
uh and secondly he could only delay it
even if congress agreed for a month
because
the the uh inauguration of january 20th
is set in the constitution
i think the president is just trying to
get people talking about the danger
of or the what he thinks the inaccuracy
the possibilities for fraud
in mainland voting but having said that
he is just gonna set
people's uh hair on fire and you know
the
joe biden in april said i bet you
that that president trump is gonna try
to find a way to delay the election and
the president
came back that same month and said no i
haven't been thought about it tell joe
he can rest easy i promise you those
clips will be played
i just don't understand why the
president would want to stoke
this brush fire well i guess uh
setting up this this complaint that mail
in voting will have been fraudulent then
in a very close election you could do
something like
republican state legislators can say hey
this is all too murky we're going to
appoint electors ourselves
and throw it and throw our electoral
votes to president trump that's going to
end up in the supreme court
yeah uh oh you know the supreme court of
course
just ruled that that faithless electors
uh people that don't vote for the
popular vote winner
are uh you know are not allowed and
they're subject to sanctions so
i don't know it it it just strikes me it
at a time you know i i find this
president
what a revelation uh
curious and turbulent to cover because
you know sometimes he's
he sticks to the script and he seems to
be very conventional and serious
and then he says something like this i
mean one of the things i wonder the gdp
the gross domestic product of the
country contract you know normally it's
up
one percent three percent something like
that it was minus 32
and you wonder to what degree was he
just trying to get people's minds
off that horrible news and the fact that
another 1.4 million people
applied for new unemployment claims this
week and get them talking you know
the shiny object up in the corner but it
just strikes me is
as an odd thing to do and with people
questioning
this president and you know with the
divisiveness that he elicits
whether this is helpful to him or not
well uh
if that's the case and it may very well
be that it worked at least with me i
would have started this conversation
with the economy and then he throws this
tweet out there and
and we're off to the races on that now
serious or not a guy who feels confident
in winning doesn't even suggest delaying
the election and there are reports that
he's concerned about texas
that he's basically giving up on
michigan although he has so much money i
don't know why he just can't compete
hard everywhere
and he's also been talking about he's
been conceding geez i guess people don't
like me
uh comparing himself to dr anthony fauci
and
and joe biden in the polls yeah a lot of
those comments i find
i find odd uh
you know and some of them he said in his
interview with me at the white house a
week
10 days ago look i don't think there's
any doubt
he's losing right now i mean you look at
the national polls
you look at the the state polls and most
importantly
you look at the actions not the words
but the actions who's
running and campaigning right now
like they're ahead and who's running and
campaigning like they're behind
that doesn't mean you know we got 90
something days i think until the
election
uh doesn't mean things could change i
mean one news cycle is an eternity
in the world we live in now 90 plus of
them
uh it is an eon uh
but an era but but having said that i
i'd say right now there's no question
that
the president is behind and he's acting
like it uh joe biden says he'll announce
his
vice president pick next week time to uh
go out and snap up those biden harris
bumper stickers you think or do we not
know
well let me give you a piece of
information he's not going to announce
it next week i'm told not to expect it
next week although that biden did say
that it's probably going to be the week
after
as soon as he said in his delaware press
conference
it's going to be next week a lot of
people in the democratic party
were saying wait a minute that's way too
long in advance of the convention
uh this is kind of a a nothing burger
anyway the convention you want to do
everything you can to maintain
the suspense and then have the momentum
of the announcement
uh and and you know coming just before
the convention so i'm told it'll be the
week of the 10th not
not the week of the third as to who it's
going to be i have
absolutely no idea and no intelligence i
mean
on this subject um you know and and
everybody i talk to
just doesn't you know i i i wouldn't
expect anybody to give you
but i've i've been asking well is there
a shorter list because there were a
dozen names on the longer list and
i'm told uh you know we're not going to
say
so and so isn't really a serious
candidate because we don't really know
what's in the vice president's head
you know i can see strong reasons for
kamala harris uh
she's run you know she's an attractive
candidate
she's uh has been able to generate
crowds
uh she represents a state actually he
doesn't need
to win if he can't win california he's
going to lose 49 states anyway
uh but you know she's you you can
understand the reasons for her
but do i think she's a shoe-in
absolutely not i'm not saying she won't
get it but i don't think i wouldn't say
that she's the prohibited favorite at
this point
a couple of big house hearings this week
um seem like blown opportunities to me
you get attorney general william barr up
there under oath you get the heads of
facebook google and amazon up there
under oath
and you spend all your time making
speeches and just fighting with each
other i didn't learn a thing
i couldn't agree more uh let's talk
particularly about
the tech hearing there have been you
know every year or two
there's a tech hearing and they you know
this is the first time i think that
bezos has
testified but zuckerberg has certainly
testified before tim cook of apple has
testified before
and you know the the left the the
democrats hit
them from the left on questions of of uh
monopolies and and anti-competitiveness
republicans hit them on issues of
political bias and nothing ever seems to
come out of them
and uh and and this seemed to be just
exactly one more
case of that the uh so so i don't know i
mean i'm not i never expected anything
from it nothing
nothing came i thought the the bar
hearing which i took somewhat more
seriously
was an embarrassment you know i i
understand
nothing i agree with but i understand
the reasons why democrats really don't
like him and
and feel that barr has become uh the
the political henchman and a much more
conventional
attorney general because you know
historically attorney attorneys general
have very much had the back of their
president who appoints them i mean even
with you know the extreme example of
bobby kennedy
with jack kennedy in in 1961
but wouldn't you think they'd actually
like to get an answer as as they say
as far said at one point this is a
hearing don't you want to hear from me
and the answer is no they didn't they
just wanted to excoriate them and
ask their question and then we learned
this new phrase i would reclaim my time
they'd ask a question and then say i
reclaimed my time
which basically meant don't waste my
time with your answer i just want to
shoot more mean questions actually
herman cain died
74 years old infected with the
coronavirus he was co-chair of the group
black voices for trump hospitalized a
week and a half after attending the
president's rally in tulsa oklahoma in
june although it's impossible to know if
he was infected there
cain was a business executive and
republican presidential candidate
i remember when he ran uh it was
it was a 2012 i believe that he ran and
and
i had him on the show and at one point
we were talking about the middle east it
was a hot issue
and i asked him about uh but do you
agree with the palestinians on the right
to return and he knew nothing about it
and he went the right to return the rich
return
and to his credit the last the next time
he was on and that's the question of
whether or not
palestinian refugees as part of the
peace deal should be able to come back
and reclaim the territory they had
before they were expelled
in the 1940s it's a big issue in the
middle east the next time that
herman cain came on the show and i said
welcome back to fox news sundays and i
just want to tell you i'm exercising my
right of return which was a pretty funny
line
and uh he he was a very pleasant person
to interview
chris wallace host of fox news sunday
thanks chris you're a very pleasant
person to interview as well
i'm not sure everybody would agree with
that but thank you chris and i'll talk
to you next week
this is john you with your fox news
commentary
coming up one recent satirical headline
read
nevada church avoids coronavirus
restrictions
by installing slot machines no word on
any church
actually doing that but the satire was
written shortly after the supreme court
weighed in
on state restrictions on houses of
worship during covet
in a 5-4 ruling the justices refused to
strike down nevada's 50-person cap
on worship in a dissenting opinion
justice samuel alito wrote he was
disappointed by the court's decision
that while there is a constitutional
guarantee of the free exercise of
religion
it says nothing about the freedom to
play craps or blackjack
this wasn't the first case of its kind
in new york a federal judge
ruled against the state's limits on
indoor and outdoor services last month
so have judges in kentucky and north
carolina but judges in places like
california have sided with city and
state officials on the church limits
in california the guidelines also said
at churches holding services that
singing should be discouraged to limit
the spread of the virus
it might not matter much right now
church and synagogue services are on
hold again in most california counties
some of you may have continued to go to
church or synagogue and some of us
have not depending on where we live and
depending on how vulnerable we are to
the virus
the limitations have been hard
especially since during a pandemic
one of the things many of us want to do
is pray well we've gone through a range
of regulations here in
texas in dallas county which is a hot
spot
when the pandemic first started we
shut down along with every other venue
in the city of dallas
robert jeffress is the pastor at first
baptist dallas
and a fox news contributor but then the
governor
greg abbott intervened after a period of
time
in april and he urged churches to go
ahead and open in a safe way
and we started doing that uh the
governor called me we talked about the
process of reopening for our church
and we said we were going to be a little
more cautious and perhaps
wait until the first sunday in june so
we did that
we have opened up we have about 30
percent of our capacity right now
meeting we went a little bit over that
when the vice president was here on june
the 28th
but we continue to host in-person
services and also
online every sunday we have several
hundred thousand people that worship
with us
online when the president watched and
when the vice president was here we had
over a million people watching online so
that's our model right now both
in-house and online worship so it does
sound like there
are you know you're not at full capacity
and maybe some of those who are more
more vulnerable or older or have health
conditions maybe aren't going
are you hearing from them are they sad
are they bummed out that they can't go
yes i mean
there is a natural instinct especially
among christians that in a time of
crisis
you gather together i mean i remember so
well
after 9 11 that was on a tuesday and the
next sunday the church i
pastored was filled to the brim with
people who wanted to be with one another
and yet
we can't do that right now and so those
who can't come they're saddened by it
but they also know this pandemic is
going to pass at some point
and they look forward to coming back to
worship for those who maybe
actually have the virus or know somebody
who's either passed or suffered with it
you know or maybe even just people who
are afraid of the virus afraid of
actually getting it
you know what do you what do you tell
people
i mean like especi like i'm i'm
imagining some some
some pastors and rabbis going back in
time and saying
what did what did people tell their
congregants you know during the bubonic
plague you know like is there any sort
of like wisdom about like
how you counsel people right now you
know i think one reason this virus has
been so
troubling to people is it has shattered
the illusion
that we're in control of our own lives
i remember in the beginning of the year
in january as i do on every new year's
day making a list of all the things i
thought i was going to be doing in 2020
and i imagine god was laughing as i made
that list
because i ended up doing none of those
things i couldn't foresee
what awaited us and i think there has
been a breaking of that illusion that we
set our own destiny
but i think that's a good thing as well
and what i say to people who are fearful
of the pandemic
is first of all those of us who value
life and say we're pro-life
we ought to be the ones leading the
parade to take care of our lives
and to prevent the spread of this
disease i think we have a responsibility
to do that
but also try to calm people with the
assurance that look statistically
you're not going to probably die from
this pandemic
but statistically you're going to die
from something you know somebody said
the statistics on death are very
impressive
one out of every one dies and so
i think this pandemic is a reminder that
we need to be prepared for death
and we need to make sure we're in the
right relationship with god
and that's the bottom line for everyone
well i'm jewish and i know
you know they're there are we we have
conversations about you know like
what this all means like you were saying
uh you know the philosophical right
and and there is sort of this
you know i don't know if the word
apocalypse is too strong but there's an
apocalyptic
feeling to you know a pandemic right
when
when you know and i don't know if you
you guys are having that same kind of
talk like it feels
very big right it's not just an
individual illness
or individual sickness it's global what
do you
what do you tell people about scripture
and what we know about um about what the
bible tells us about
these sort of events these big events
it's so interesting because a year ago i
began
a verse by verse study from the book of
revelation the apocalypse
about the end times little did i know
when i planned this series
that in the middle of that series we
would be going through
you know the the the demon hornets or
whatever they
the murder hold on yeah all of those
things going on
uh i assure people we are not in the
apocalypse right now because
i mean the fact is the bible in the new
testament gives some very specific
things that have to happen
before those final seven years of
earth's history
the rapture of the church the rebuilding
of the temple in jerusalem
the appearance of the antichrist and so
forth so we're not there yet
but i think it's a precursor of what the
world is going to experience at one time
and the most important thing is
i remember so well speaking of being
jewish one of my best friends at fox
news was the late alan combs and
allen was jewish and we had many
discussions about faith
and he asked me on one of his last
programs he said pastor do you believe
you're going to live
to see jesus coming back again and i
said alan you know what
it really isn't that important and he
was surprised he said why do you say
that
i said because i'm 58 years old and i
know that in the next 30 years
either he's coming or i'm going but one
way or the other i'm going to meet god
and i better be ready for it
now being ready for many means learning
reading growing even if you can't go to
church or in rabbi bregman's case
synagogue he like pastor jeffress has
noticed a big uptick in online
consumption of spiritual material
everybody is just i really think you
know in a mode
of pivoting and sincerely trying their
best if trying their best to participate
to worship to feel something
and to remain connected under these
super trying times
rabbi how have you been touched
personally by the virus
i i would sort of start by with sort of
two elements
um so number one my own
uh rabbi my roshi she but my own
personal torah mentor was a world famous
torah sage
passed the way of kovid in the beginning
of this
in the beginning of the pandemic and it
was you know
very shocking as he was a relatively
young man
uh you know only in his 50s and but of
course i couldn't go
to his funeral and so
instead of somebody having tens of
thousands of people who would have gone
to their funeral
it's it's on zoom and it's his it's his
sons and his father there
i believe so it's you know just just you
know that's been very eerie number one
number two
um my wife and i were blessed with a
child
approximately about five months ago a
little girl
who was born with it yes yes yes thank
you
i'll take the mazel tov with a
congenital heart defect
so we've been basically
uh living mostly in around the hospitals
and the icus uh for about five months
but it's been
quite complicated because a layered on
top of
having uh holes in your heart you know
and being a newborn
you know you're you're carrying the
stress of the change world
and and the germs so everything has been
completely upside down
and layering you know a thick layer of
cream cheese on top of that bagel if you
know what i'm saying so
i've been impacted in many ways but i'll
just leave you i'll give you those two
for starters
rabbi and me your daughter what is her
name
her uh her name is ellie cheva
may she be blessed with 100 complete
refusal emma
um please no we'll take it thank you
before i let you go just i want your
theological perspective here you know
i've i've had conversations with my
friends i imagine
many people who are maybe more observant
or find themselves you know feel more
religious have had these conversations
too about
you know what does torah what does the
bible teach us about
not just hardship but maybe specifically
health related
hardships i know a lot of people right
now feel like you know this isn't just a
you know a personal health hardship
right this is a pandemic this is global
what can we take away from the text um
about this time um this is one of the
most common questions that uh
rabbis and other faith leaders are being
asked this time of year
and certainly over the last many months
what does this mean uh is the messiah
coming
is the world coming to an end you know
what does this mean
i've been advising people that this
would be a prime time
to focus on things that perhaps we
should have been focused on
more all along uh connection
planning for the future flexibility
being flexible with one another tolerant
a little bit more patient there's things
that you know all of us can
be working on or should have been
working on it's what we say in uh
yiddish
there's an expression that menstruating
which means it's a famous we find this
in many cultures that uh
that a person a man makes plans and god
laughs
right right so we've been saying that
that yiddish expression for hundreds of
years and
it's known throughout the world but
we're seeing it now more than ever
rabbi bregman thank you so much
for your time
you're very very welcome
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to the untold story
with martha mccallum the host of the
story on fox news channel sits down with
major newsmakers
each week to get their untold story
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
girl scout troop 6000 burst onto the
national scene in april 2017 when they
grew
famous seemingly overnight the new york
city troop is unique
made up entirely of girls who are
experiencing homelessness
it started at a shelter in queens by
giselle burgess
who was working as a community
engagement specialist for the girl
scouts of greater new york
and who along with her five children was
also without a home
she pitched the idea of starting the
troop in the shelter to her bosses
and the rest is history nikita stewart
is a reporter for the new york times and
wrote the very first
story on troop 6000 the one that went
viral
after that story living by the girl
scout law even without a home
was published on april 16 2017
the girls were profiled on national news
programs websites and even recognized
on the tonight show starring jimmy
fallon there was just so much
attention and people were praising them
but you know they would go to all of
these
wonderful places and they would go on
these field trips they would meet
famous people and they were on tv
but you know i think it's easy to forget
that you know they were still
returning to a shelter each night
now nikita brings us up to date on
what's happened with the troops since
then
in her new book about them entitled
troop 6000
the girl scout troop that began in a
shelter and inspired the world
i followed them for more than a year
going to the meetings each friday
and watching troop 6000
grow and there are a lot of bumps along
the way
but it is absolutely incredible to see
how the troop has gone from eight girls
to hundreds of girls in now
21 shelters around new york city
even the troops number is unique in new
york city the first digit of a girl
scout troops number corresponds to the
borough it's from
1 thousands in the bronx 2 thousands in
brooklyn
but since the girls of the new troop
wouldn't necessarily call queens home
a new number was created what was
wonderful about
troop 6000 and the girl scouts that
you know despite all of the instability
that so many of the girls had
experienced
they knew that every friday
there was gonna be a girl scout meeting
and they were going to see their friends
and the things that girls nationwide
enjoy about scouting the badges and the
cookies and the camping
brought an even greater meaning to troop
6000 they all come together
for a an event called world thinking day
and when you see
hundreds of girls in the same uniforms
with the same number
and you know that they too
are experiencing homelessness there's
just a shared community
and an understanding that they're not
alone
nikita says the majority of the original
troop members are now in permanent
housing but they still stay in touch
and i can't believe how many of the
girls you know
became like bffs and they found each
other
at troop 6000 and i just think that's
really special
troupe 6000 the girl scout troop that
began in a shelter and inspired the
world by nikita stewart
is out now tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
john
you what's on your mind justice ruth
bader ginsburg unfortunately now she is
suffering recurrence of cancer her fifth
and we wish her all the best if she were
have to step down for medical reasons
there would be an opening on the court
and that should serve as a reminder to
conservatives why they supported
president trump in the first place
many who were wary of trump in 2016
threw their support behind him because
they believed he would appoint
conservative judges who would hold the
supreme court's
relentless march to the left
conservatives however may now feel like
charlie brown trying to kick the
football even though trump had the
opportunity to nominate justices neil
gorsuch and brett kavanaugh
the court nevertheless rejected the
administration's positions
on immigration gay rights and abortion
this term
to finally give conservatives a robust
majority on the supreme court
they will have to redouble their efforts
in the coming november election
trump still has every right to trumpet
his successes with judicial appointments
after justice antonin scalia's untimely
death in february 2016
the court remained divided between four
liberal justices and four conservatives
central constitutional concerns
including religious freedom
property rights the death penalty and
gun control
remained up for grabs depending on the
next president's appointment
of scalia's replacement but trump did
more than make the same promises of
republicans past
during a critical point in the
republican primary race in 2016
trump made an unprecedented commitment
not only would he pick conservative
justices but
to prove it he released a list of at
first 10 and 20
names from which he would select supreme
court justices
no nominee had ever issued a short list
of supreme court nominees
many conservatives made peace with trump
because of his promises to appoint a
justice
like a scalia or a clarence thomas who
would overturn
roe versus wade on this promise trump
has come through
in just two years trump has changed the
trajectory of constitutional law
before the appointments of gorsuch and
kavanaugh conservatives and liberals
both contended for the fifth vote of
justice kennedy
whose libertarian instincts had led him
to uphold roe versus wade
and find a constitutional right to gay
marriage
but also to uphold affirmative action in
college admissions
and limit religion in the public square
while this jury may still be out on the
appointments they appear to share a
healthy respect for the founders
and interest in the natural law thinking
and a disdain for past supreme court
precedent
should justice ginsburg or another
liberal justice retire the white house
would have the opportunity
to cement a more secure sixth justice
conservative majority
trump could set the agenda of
constitutional law for the next quarter
century
after justice kennedy's departure the
most liberal member of the
republican-appointed majority on the
court
becomes chief justice roberts roberts
has disappointed conservatives first in
his two decisions upholding obamacare
from constitutional statutory challenges
and then in this terms gay rights
immigration and abortion decisions
nevertheless the chief justice has led
the court in a more conservative
direction such as restoring limits on
the federal government
particularly his powers to spend
regulate commerce and enforce racial
distinctions
if the supreme court doesn't reach these
and other long-held conservative goals
it would only be because chief justice
roberts
sees his role as limiting the political
consequences of a trump
counter-revolution on the court
only by securing another seat on the
court
will conservatives have a sufficient
majority to curtail chief justice
roberts's political maneuverings
in favor of a constitution of fixed
original
meaning this has been john yu law
professor
at the university of california at
berkeley and the author
of defender in chief donald trump's
fight for presidential power
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes